what's going on everybody welcome to
part 7 of the Python 3 basics series in
this part we're going to be talking a
little bit more on functions and this
time we're going to be talking about
function parameters and then
implementing those for our game mostly
because pretty much every time you know
we're gonna import a user's movement and
then we're going to call game board
again and every time there's a play
we're gonna in theory be doing that and
so I think it would make more sense to
go ahead and include the play in the
game board function so before we do that
I'm just gonna comment this out really
quickly and we're gonna do some quick
examples and then apply it to what we
have so first of all let's just do
define and we're gonna make a super
simple function that takes x and y and
then it just returns X plus y so it just
does addition obviously we don't you
know you don't need a function for this
you could just say some variable equals
x plus y ur you know 5 plus 2 or
whatever but this is just for simplicity
sake so what if we said print you know
addition 5 & 3 well of course the output
here is going to be 8 so then you know
you could also assign this you could say
Z equals addition 5 3 and then you could
print Z pretty much the same thing so
the other thing that I just want to
bring up quickly - as far as parameters
are concerned and really definitions of
variables is like what happens if we
change this up like what if what if we
take in hey and there and just so looks
pretty a lot of space and we print that
out well this time these things added
together are actually just like two
strings being appended to each other so
that works too but what if we did like a
5 and there and we try that okay that
gets really angry at us right because we
can't actually the the actual addition
the whole thing where we're actually
adding things together the method
for these two types of data are not the
same so these two types of objects
integer and string there is no
methodology for adding them together
therefore we can't actually do that now
this kind of brings home a slight point
with Python that we don't normally have
typing information so Python is let's
just do back to hey python is what we
call dynamically typed as in the
variables that we use and pass and stuff
like when we define a variable we
actually don't say hey variable X is an
int or a float whereas a lot of
programming languages will require you
to do that and but in Python we don't
have to now this is a gift and a curse
at the same time because of dynamic
typing we the you know in the back end
the program has to be prepared for the
for the case where hey this might right
now it could be an integer but tomorrow
or the next time it comes through it
could actually be a float or a string or
something else right so so in Python
that takes a little bit more overhead to
process so you can specify types in
Python if you want to so you could say X
and I think and the only reason I say I
think is because I actually don't I
can't remember for sure I think this is
how you do it and in fact let's just try
and for summary so like this I think is
an annotation there is a way and
annotations people don't use either and
there is a way I believe that you can
specify an enforce typing and Python I
honestly forget what it is and I have
never ever seen it used in practice
people just don't do it so the only time
I've ever seen something like this in
practice is with something called scythe
on which is a way for you basically to
whoops not Python Python
it's a way for you to implement
basically your Python program and get it
pretty much as best as possible
converted to C but most of the work that
you're going to be doing there is
literally adding typing information
we're at the heck here we go yeah so
rather than doing def you might do a
seed F or a CP def but then you would
you actually give it typing information
but more on that later or if you're
interested in learning more about scythe
on you can just go or type in scythe on
on Python programming net okay so let's
get back to our game board example so
I'm just gonna bring it up and basically
what I'd like to be able to do is pass
the player into into game boards so
there's a lot of different ways that we
can utilize parameters we can we can
basically make a parameter required to
be passed or we can specify like a
default value for that parameter and
then the user doesn't actually have to
pass a value if they don't want to so in
our case why might we want to not have
to pass like so let's say we want to
pass maybe the game board make the
player number and then where does that
player want to play what would there
ever be a time when we didn't want to
pass any of those well what if we just
want to you know just see the game board
like at the start of the game we might
want to do that therefore we might want
to wave for this function to not
actually require any input from the user
or in our case from the programmer who's
just like programming the logic here so
first of all let's just make it super
simple and let's say for this now we
want to let's just say we want to get
rid of this for now so we're gonna pass
what do we need well we need the you
know basically in this case the row
column and then this is the player
number so we need all those things so we
need row column and then and then I kind
of want to put player first so player
like that so now these parameters in
order to run this function we have to
pass these parameters so if I just like
comment these two things out we try to
run this it's gonna get angry with us
because we didn't actually pass any of
the required parameters I mean just yeah
so this is the actual error it throws
and it says hey game board is missing
three of the required positional
arguments and it even tells us hey you
got to pass these things and if we just
pass one of the things like we'll pass a
one here we're still missing two more
we're missing row and column because it
goes in order so the next thing you
might be aware of is to pass a value for
player we really could just pass one and
then let's say we want to play on row 2
column 0 we can pass things like this 1
2 & 0 so I could run this and everything
works obviously we didn't play a
specific place yet because we haven't
handled for that but we're able to run
the function by passing them like this
but later on like right now game board
is right underneath our functions
definition so it's pretty legible
because we can always just like glance
up here but in long code that's not
gonna be legible right so if you're
passing hard values like that that's
gonna be pretty hard but what if your
variable name is literally you know
current player and then a row choice
call choice right in that case if you've
named your variables pretty good names
you definitely still don't need any more
information anybody reading this code is
like okay I know it's being passed but
in our case what if we don't because we
are just kind of hard coding them how
can we handle for that well you can also
just say player equals one row equals is
2 and then column equals 0 we could run
that again everything worked the other
thing you can do is you can kind of you
can mix it up so you could for example
you could say just one here row two
column 0 that's totally fine and then
the other thing we can do is add
defaults to the
gameboard so player could we could
default to zero ro can default to zero
and column can default to zero so we
might want to do this just so that this
function could be run and just like if
we just want to see the game board we
could run that and everything's fine
right so now let's add our logic for
actually marking up this game board so
what we'll do is right here we will just
say let's just say game and then row and
then column so these values these
variables here are just whatever value
is passed through those parameters we
can just say that equals whatever the
player was passed and this is y 0 0 0 is
gonna work just fine it's just gonna set
everything to 0 at least for now
because later if we've actually played
here and if a player actually has a
position on the game board we're gonna
set that position as 0
and that's not going to be very good but
for now it works just fine
and then later if we were to say game
board let's just run it again and then
we're gonna play player equals 1 row
equals 2 column equals 1 or something
like that we can see ok yeah it's been
marked there so the only other thing I
might say here is maybe if we said like
we definitely want to have some sort of
handling for how you know how do we want
to actually display the game if we
didn't pass anything here so and the
other the other thing to note is like
let's see so what we could say here is
just if if player not actually does not
equal 0 or something like that
whoops and then just tab this over then
play it this way you also could have
like a little flag like that might even
make more sense like just display and
just display could equal
false to start and then instead you
could say if if not just display display
just display it was false so then you
could say here just display equals true
in this case if we scroll up we get just
the purely display and we didn't set 0 0
equals 0 because again if let's say
someone had actually played at that 0 0
mark we would be in trouble alright so
so now if just display is equal to true
so if not just display so if just
display we're not gonna actually run
this code and then otherwise no matter
what happens we want to print out the
game board so I think that's a decent
place for us to stop but I want to start
talking about what about this game board
being defined outside of our function
and then we're using our function to
modify the game board right now that's
working and everything's fine we're not
running into any problems doing that but
as long as you continue down this path
of doing things that way like modifying
a function or modifying a thing that's
outside of your function you're gonna
find some weird things start happening
and if you don't learn either how to
properly do it every time correctly or
how to just kind of do it by habit and
just always get the thing that you want
later on down the road you're gonna be
pulling your hair out trying to figure
out why your programming isn't doing
what you know it should be doing but yet
at the same time you know programming is
infinitely logical and you're making a
mistake somewhere and it just is driving
you nuts so in the next tutorial we're
going to be talking about the concepts
of mutability and immutable immutability
which we've already somewhat talked
about but this is kind of a different a
different variation on that topic so
anyways that's what we're gonna be doing
in the next tutorial a
quick shout out to my most recent
sponsors I'm gonna have a really hard
time with some of these names I'm gonna
call you
tib the penguin mr. wekki or wedgie I'm
not sure I'm gonna go with wacky Erica
and Joseph Coleman thank you guys very
much for your support
and I think that is it I will see you
guys in the next video